is being a YouTube Creator
recession-proof and how can you prepare
for an uncertain economy I'm more
worried about Netflix than I'm worried
about YouTube when other people get
fearful get greedy lean into your
content phone time will only increase
they're being a little tighter on their
budget and this is a brand that we work
with that can be scary to hear that
great successes are made in times like
this when people just leaned in when
other people were afraid
in this episode of the think media
podcast I'm going to be talking with
Omar and Nolan and we're going to be
discussing some of the trends that are
happening in the economy we're actually
going to be looking at a brand new
article that reveals some must-know data
and really kind of exploring this idea
of how do you be a recession-proof
business owner entrepreneur and content
creator and so welcome back to the
podcast I opened up this article from
Mashable and I just thought like we have
to talk about it and right now everyone
is worried that we're going into a
recession I mean the hype right now is
that eggs are super overpriced and the
fanciest place to take a date was a meme
I saw was to the egg aisle at Safeway
and uh World economic Forum found that
nearly two-thirds of respondents believe
there's going to be a recession in 2023
and so there's a lot of kind of drama
there's a lot of things happening but on
the other side NPR reports that a lot of
analysis think it's just going to be a
small r or session it's not going to be
crazy and right now there are two
million full-time content creators and
46 million amateurs I know the article
they're quoting there I don't even think
that's updated information Adobe stated
that 165 million people joined the
Creator economy since 2020. so the
crater economy is this massive industry
I've got some data here but I'm just
curious your hot take when you hear the
question is the crater economy
recession-proof Omar little our
recession because we serve a big G God
um the first thing that comes to mind
honestly is yes it is Recession Proof
but it's if you build your content or
your creator business differently right
like in many cases articles like this
are referring to ad spend or things that
other people are paying for you to
create content but the cool thing about
content creation is if you have
something underneath you own
um then you can protect yourself and you
probably will see an increase in
recession during the recession kind of
like 2020 we experience at think media
just a huge boost overall in views in
engagement in customers and so I I think
the recession actually is going to bring
more people on as business owners who
have brick and mortar are going to be
like I need to be a Creator in the
recession you know what I am looking at
is in our YouTube Studio I'm just like
when it comes to AdSense I know that is
just one small piece of the pie when it
comes to uh how creators are making
money but I think a lot of haters get
scared about AdSense because for a lot
of people I'm not saying it's smart to
do this but they solely rely on AdSense
and so
um one of the things that I was looking
at is in 2021 uh versus 2022 starting at
the beginning of the year in like
January advertisers were paying us more
I think media to be in front of our
content so but what was interesting was
you'll see on the screen here about
halfway through if you're watching on
the YouTube channel if not go watch on
the YouTube channel as well but uh
halfway through the lines kind of
crossed and uh by the end of the year of
2022 advertisers were paying us less but
we still made more money because we have
more views coming in and so uh is it a
huge difference no not not really but
like we're seeing you know 13 versus 18
cpms which is still pretty substantial
so I guess to answer your question uh do
I don't I I don't know what's going to
happen I'm not worried uh and maybe
that's just me not knowing a ton about
you know economics all that kind of
stuff but just I really think Creator
economy I think YouTubers
are like the future I think it is the
future
um and so I'm more worried about Netflix
than I'm worried about YouTube it's
interesting you know a couple things
that stood out to me in this was
according to Glassdoor the average
amount of money content creators make is
48 800 and that was for 2022. what do
you think about that
how much was that
uh an equivalent of a 48 800 salary the
average Creator according to Glassdoor
that's awesome
uh this is something garyvee talks about
how we're going into a time where you
can make a decent salary doing what you
love talking about things you love
things that interest you and nobody
telling you what to do yes
um so
yeah I mean you know like I think when
you scale it up you can see this like
the large you know conglomerate
YouTubers creators take some sort of a
hit they feel it but hopefully I'm even
obviously if you're wise and you don't
you know you uh live below your means
and you're just wise with your finances
and how you have multiple streams of
income within your content you're gonna
be okay but I think it's still the
recession only for me uh poses the
opportunity that people should lean into
creating content because people are
still going to be on their phones and
during recession if not phone time will
only increase as depression decreases
that's a great point and it says in this
article the reason they consider it
Recession Proof or recession resistant
which is a powerful term is because it's
driven by direct financial support from
audiences and the Creator's ability to
connect with fans which is typically
less affected by economic fluctuations
so there's kind of a bubble around
creators and also if they're smart they
need to be earning money in multiple
ways and it states that with sponsored
posts creators typically net
around a hundred dollars per ten
thousand followers then they also sell
merch they have their own Goods
affiliate links and making money off the
prep platforms their self and so what do
you think about that people always ask
how much do brand deals pay I actually
think that at think media we have kind
of carved out a brand and a value where
we get paid pretty significantly more
than the views we get I think maybe
because of the quality of the content
because of the positioning but what do
you think you know our community too
it's so you know it's so targeted as
well and it's kind of like a high or you
know RPM type of uh Niche just typically
too
what do you think about that a hundred
dollars for 10 000 followers that means
if you have a hundred thousand followers
you'd get a thousand dollars per post
it's so hard to like every Niche is so
different so it really depends on what
kind of content you're making and so you
know maybe that could be a general
number but like it could be so much
higher if you have a very specific
targeted audience that is making a lot
of money and and those people spend a
lot of money
um you know just in this article too
that we're looking at they mentioned you
know AdSense being anywhere from like
three to five dollars per thousand video
views I'm like well that's true but I
think media we're making much more than
that it's like we're making twenty
Thirty forty dollar cpms yeah
RPMs yeah so you know I think I think
that number's conservative and I think
um it could be a lot a lot higher and I
think brand deals though is is kind of
underrated when it comes to people
finding Brands and Partnerships that
you're already using and partnering with
them you know it's just such a cool way
rather than building your own product we
see a lot of YouTubers right now trying
to start businesses
um you know or or partner with other
businesses I think partnering is is such
a smart move especially when you're
already using it you're already
promoting it you talk about it all the
time it's it just so much frictionless
so that yeah the tip in that is
one way to precession proof your content
or your Channel or what have you is to
create long-term deals uh with companies
because it would protect you and you
could you could plan out financially
things because you know what's coming in
and it's like there's a contract uh but
that's funny how you bring that up with
like creators wanting to be business
owners and business owners want to be
creators Sarah DG brought this up that
there's a line that Drake has and it
says music and sports it's so synonymous
because we want to be them and they want
to be us and right now we're living in a
time where creators want to be CEOs and
entrepreneurs we have entrepreneurs it's
and CEOs who want to be creators and
it's like this funny Clash that's
happening
um that you know it's kind of like which
one are you I mean can you be both you
know there's there's probably some that
are there's better you're better off
probably just staying as a Creator but I
don't know it's just like a funny
Dynamic that we're starting to see in a
little bit I'm gonna ask you your kind
of tactical tips of how you would
prepare for an uncertain Financial year
here but this block of the article I
think is important to talk about and
it's all about some of the trends that
we're seeing in influencer marketing and
this is a really great sign because even
though some people are certainly saying
deals are being canceled for certain
creators
um and that it feels like there is some
companies that are pulling back in their
spending but here's what the data is
telling us just in the U.S alone there
is estimated to be 4.6 billion dollars
spent on influencer marketing in 2023
that is doubled what they spent just
five years ago so there's more money
going into the system 65 percent of
Brands expect to increase their budget
for influencer marketing that's more
money going into the system to creators
and what they're also seeing is that
trust is the huge key to people actually
making purchases and Nielsen's consumer
trust index reports that 92 percent of
consumers trust influencer marketing
over traditional no advertising and a
new study shows that 53 percent of
people say they'd be more likely to buy
a product if it's recommended to them by
a member of their Community they belong
to like a content creator finally the
influencer marketing content delivers 11
times better Roi than traditional
advertising methods according to Forbes
so what do you see the opportunity is
for upstart creators that maybe feel
like there's an uphill battle for
getting started and in uncertain times
when it comes to all of this money and
opportunity flowing into Brands wanting
to work with and sponsor creators Nolan
well I think you know Kyle and I we were
meeting with a company that we that we
work with at think media and you know
they mentioned that this year you know
the the top you know execs are saying
that they're being a little tighter on
their budget and this is uh you know a
brand that we work with and so that can
be scary to hear that because you know
you have big brands that you know you
think are doing well making a lot of
money but they are pulling back a little
bit it can be kind of intimidating
um but my my optimism is that
creators I think will always win in the
end if yeah we talk about reputation and
staying true to your character if you
don't sell your soul to the good deal
just because it's bringing in the
paycheck because one company is you know
the company you like they they're not
spending as much right now but some
other company is you know we're looking
the whole FTX thing and like they're
going all out they're giving you cash
you know you get the check and um you
don't really back it but you know I
think what creators need to do is live
below their means save up cash continue
producing content more people are gonna
keep watching content and figure out
this whole you know as things change I
think creators uh can can still Thrive
and just stay true to who you are and
and don't just do stuff for the money
that's like that just one of the things
that we um at think media when we work
with bands we want to make sure we
really align with them and so you know
we work with some really cool brands
that we used just before we ever signed
a brand deal with them and I think I
think people can get too early into
brand deals and ultimately though I am
optimistic that uh creators uh you know
will do well but just like they got to
keep that in mind yeah I mean where I
hedged and it's just kind of the season
this will be like the second recession I
I would live and live to see and uh saw
how it affected my family in 2008 and
but then now I'm seeing how you can make
a decision to not even
let it affect you like how about when
people are pulling back lean in Warren
Buffett Warren Buffett says when other
people get fearful get greedy like
lean into your content like go upload
like make a decision to like guess the
pedal and and create more create more
value in you that you you become
recession-proof that like if you wanted
to start something you could and people
would flock and I think there's just so
much power in that if you have the
attention you have the audience or
you're building that audience
um that you can you can do it gives you
the freedom to do what you want so that
when the world is doing its thing
you could combat that with something you
know you know I think you know we we see
it now like what what a blessing it is
to be Educators in content as the
world's moving into this direction but
we were just staying true to ourselves
we leaned into our gifts that God has
given us and and and that's being
honored by our way being to to serve an
audience and so now we can get creative
like okay recession like should we do
in-person stuff should we do like
intimate stuff uh should we create more
programs like it just allows for actual
create more creativity because they say
that it's oftentimes in constraints you
actually become more creative and so I
think it's more or less just leaning
into this season don't let it I don't
think the fear don't don't be motivated
by fear I I would say lean into the
opportunities I love Alex and Mosey
tweeted this a little bit ago he said
opportunity only looks like opportunity
when you look back and missed it because
when opportunity is presented it looks
like Risk
so what are maybe some risks you could
make in this recession and I know that
sounds backwards but you know wealth's
made in times like this or you know also
great successes are made in times like
this when people just leaned in when
other people were afraid it's really
good yeah I think
the best way to respond to recession I
think for me gotta guard your mindset
if you are in a negative mindset that
has you just worrying and not being
productive that's not productive if all
you're doing is watching and reacting
and fearful but if you're productive and
posting content There's an opportunity
there I think to create multiple streams
of income you know they mentioned near
50k being kind of that average salary
salary for a content creator which
depending on where you live having
freedom and maybe that being one of your
main income streams it's pretty amazing
and then the fact that you can scale
that up as you increase your skills but
they mention a Creator Sarah Renee Clark
I actually was able to connect with her
at VidCon this past year finally for the
first time in person and she Diversified
the ways in which she brings money
including ads sponsored content and then
she has an art channel so she started
selling her own coloring books planners
color palettes and other art supplies
that go along with her artistic focused
social media recessions and that's one
of the reasons she isn't too worried
about a potential recession because she
has multiple streams of income
and so uh they've they've created
something they can sell they've
Diversified and um and by the way if you
haven't checked out our
21videotips.com we actually have a free
training where we connected with a bunch
of our creator friends and they were
just sharing some of their best
strategic information to stay at the
front of the game when it comes to video
content creation monetization and so if
you want to learn from some of the think
media voices as well as some of the best
and brightest in the industry then uh
we'll of course link that up in the show
notes or just get the free training at
21videotips.com but lastly I think um
it's about learning new skills recession
I think is an opportunity and that's
just not our idea uh Warren Buffett
recently in October was cited in saying
of 2022 that um the best way to be
inflation proof because that's another
one of the fears right is what's the
value inflation's High the value of the
dollar doesn't go as far he said was to
learn a new skill and to be become
better at what you're doing because your
skills cannot be taxed your skills
cannot be inflated away so if you're
learning new competencies if you're
learning video if you're learning
communication or video podcasting or
you're learning your camera you're
learning all this stuff especially when
people are maybe binging on fear and
worry you could be binging on education
becoming more valuable and not to just
to maybe survive the next couple years
and make it but then to launch out of
the next couple years with massive
momentum and Thrive off of the energy
you created because of Skilling up Nolan
do you have any final thoughts in
relation to tips you'd give for people
to prepare for this next year yeah I
think I think leaning into your skill
sets is huge because there's I went to
vidsummit and I just realized like how
many creators are hiring how many
creators need video editors need
vertical videos cut up like I felt like
everyone I talked to they they're
looking to expand and that also just
shows where the create Creator economy
is going and so what I'd say is like if
you're someone like me five years ago 10
years ago you love making videos you
love watching YouTube you're like I
could see myself as a YouTuber like
continue to develop those skills and you
might be going to school right now or
you just might be uh you know have your
job but like
keep building those skills and and
watching content like this and filling
your mind too you know with positive put
good stuff in your ears Gary talks about
that so much it's like
um and and so
continue to put good things in continue
to develop that stuff because like we're
hiring we are building the team there's
so many creators we know that are hiring
and building the team and so I think
there's there is opportunity just even
Beyond if you might be a solo content
creator right now that you also might
just be looking to get into it and
that's what I did I just got started
with think media and I uh I love what I
do and and and I got started and I
wasn't I joined a YouTube channel Sean
had think media and I joined and started
editing and filming some stuff and I
think that is like I think more people
need to do that I've learned so much
about YouTube literally everything I
mean I've learned about YouTube I've
been able to do this full time now it's
like it's uh it's so fun for me and I've
been able to develop those skills not by
becoming a YouTuber but by working for a
YouTuber and I think more people need to
work for YouTubers and and like don't go
to college work for a YouTuber learn
YouTube and then eventually you can do
it on your own or you just might find
like a tribe like me that you connect
with and you're like dude let's build
this together and you know that's I I
think that's like uh I I've just seen it
with Iraq and his team and they're
building Creator now and there's a ton
of different options ton of different
people out there who are building things
so much bigger than these what used to
just be solo creators in a bedroom
webcam hit record post dude Creator
comedy is is blowing up in so many
different areas that's smart inspiring
that actually kind of gets me pumped
because if times are tough it's smart to
team up strengthen numbers and not just
work for a YouTuber but literally 100 of
the business owners and entrepreneurs
that I network with and this is a pretty
big group in multiple different settings
and no hyperbole not oh exaggerating
like 100 no 100 of them need a YouTube
channel manager they need somebody that
will kind of be the shredditer or at
least just the producer that takes their
content they put on Dropbox and then
gets it on YouTube edited title
thumbnail if you develop this YouTube
skill set it's so valuable and I think
that's different than a lot of people
are thinking a lot of people are
thinking oh I just want to be the
personal brand and be on camera and even
if that's true probably one of the best
Pathways to get there is link up with
somebody else you could get paid in the
process paid to learn because you're
getting to do the thing you want to get
better at you get to experiment try to
beat your previous best no matter who
you're working for if it was seven out
of 10 before you get to work on the next
hook to try to get it to be three out of
ten and have a better video and learn
titles and so developing the skill set
of the Creator economy and being
employed and earning money off the
crater economy may not be your ad sets
account and maybe freelancing and maybe
getting hired by somebody else huge
opportunity yeah I would just probably
my I go toward encouragement Bible says
don't grow weary in doing good for in
due season you'll reap a harvest and
um a preacher once said the world says
there's four seasons but God says
there's five five seasons because
there's due season you know and you
don't know when that time if if you
creating if you're putting out that good
content and you're putting out valuable
stuff maybe your value is entertaining
and you're making people laugh in a time
like this like talk about the
opportunity to bring joy into a season
that's uh people are being
experiencing depression and things like
that I I would say don't quit the good
work that you're doing for in due season
and
um this the season could be regardless
of a recession I think that people kind
of listening to this too like we're very
optimistic about where things are going
like we see the growth of it but then
like we're also sharing how
times are getting tougher and Brands
aren't paying as much and so people are
confused like wait how are you guys
hiring a team but Brands aren't paying
you as much just kind of what are your
thoughts on like because I I go to more
people are watching our content than
ever before so like we're still growing
certain BR there's always going to be
you know a little bit of fear there or a
little bit of uh pullback but
um you know it just takes me back also
to the season of 2020 when you kind of
doubled down just with with content and
a lot of people were not spending as
much they weren't hiring new team
members and you went in the opposite
direction and
um I don't know if it just reminds me of
that season if you wanted to touch on
that yeah I mean that that mentality too
was huge That season and one of the
terms we came up with was wartime versus
peacetime leaders and so a mindset shift
that if times are tough and uncertain
you need a new operating system for that
new season you can't do what you did
yesterday and so in peacetime things are
a little bit different maybe a little
bit more relaxed you mentioned living a
little bit more frugal being a little
more wise and strategic you have a whole
other level strategy if it's wartime so
I think that's one mentality and then
Omar mentioned it earlier as well I
think that in a recession there really
is three options you can flee you can
freeze or you can fight and a lot of
people run away they totally shrink back
because it's preservation but the
problem is if that's what you do you
definitely are not going to take any
ground you also just freeze and some
people just I'm not sure what to do they
think about making a move they think
about starting a YouTube channel they
just debate it forever again you're not
going to get any results the only way to
actually score a point is to fight you
got to be on offense you do need a good
defense to win win games and that would
be that caution frugality you said take
risks but their calc regulated risks but
offense is underrated I think that
people
um there's something about pushing in
there's something about pressing forward
and there is something about the data
will always tell us that the majority of
people are going to flee and they're
going to freeze so it actually ends up
being kind of a Blue Ocean strategy in
times like this you know Joe Rogan
started his podcast in 2009 people go oh
easy yeah well he's Joe Rogan today you
know he's interviewing all these no oh
he's on Fear Factor dude nobody watched
Fear Factor like what do you mean like
that's like he's been in it he's been
doing it he started it in 2009 and he
has been doing it for 13 years you know
and so you starting your thing where are
you going to be 10 years from now 13
years from now Airbnb Uber these
different things started all in
recessions a lot of innovation can come
out of a time like this and it's the
fact that in any adversity or challenge
there is a seed of equal or greater
opportunity it if you see it if you put
in the work for it if you punch fear in
the face you know I heard I heard it
said that all that courage is is fear
that said its prayers
like courage is not the absence of fear
it's just actually moving forward with
the fear that you feel and so ultimately
do it scared do it smart but if you're
connected with good information and
you're leaning in right now and just use
the extra time so much of the YouTube
career the content creator career like
well what if I get laid off well if you
get laid off apply for a few jobs and
then hustle all day every day building
up a crater economy YouTube channel like
you could look at that Gap in your time
as a big opportunity to fill it with
learning with education with the next
thing if you do have a job but you're
uncertain then hustle in your after
hours to learn new skills start that
side hustle thing most content creators
build their you know side hustle after
their nine to five they they work on it
from eight to three in the morning or
whatever it is you just that's the
sacrifice season that it takes and so
the way we frame it I think at think
media this next year is full of
opportunity I mean every day on
Instagram I'm like rise and grind it's a
new day full of New Opportunities and
new possibilities that is a mindset that
is a perspective and uh no matter what
the economy is that is our mode of
operation